ouch so you are registered for our
my class english lessons now you have to
learn how to use the app you must
have received an email asking you
to create a username and password
once created download it  my
class app on your laptop
click on it here is the number of
credits you have left roughly one credit
representing an hour and a half course
as you can see I have 6 left
to use them you have to book a
class click on browse  hockey here you
have a selection of courts that take
place on different days and times
in the event of confinement selected
in the drop-down menu
to view the courts available
online
I'm only free during the
evenings so I'm going very swamp girl
looking for  I'm going to uncheck day time oh yes
I don't want to see
courses that are already full either
once you've finished filtering your
search
click hockey dealing with crown flec
you that  seems to be a super
interesting course but I want to know
more you can look at the details of
each course by clicking on the button
the cindy giles the course is at 6:15 p.m. this
Friday evening it's perfect I  am
free booked keep looking at
available lessons and book what
fits your schedule and
learning goals
did you enjoy learning with
a particular teacher you can
book lessons with them by
clicking the button  bike kitsch to me
i enjoyed my lessons with daniel
i can see all the lessons they
teach by clicking on the calendar icon
you can also choose your lessons by
theme just click the
by km button and start booking  your lessons
good you have booked your lessons for an
entire month you can view your
timetable by navigating to
the homepage is selected via my faux
cadiot if for some reason you
cannot ass  ister at your court you
can cancel up to 24 hours
in advance by clicking on carrasso and
finally you can follow your progress
by clicking on the proof icon
here you will be able to view the
notes of your evaluations it often does us
good  when we see how much we
have progressed and that's all said we ca
n't wait to see you in class bye